it feels like the versus thing's over
right but did they ever approach you to
do something yeah who was it against or
who were they proposing
I think they was talking ll at one point
they was talking Scarface at one point
um
you said no yeah I said no I said no too
I wouldn't know uh
versus is good
but my concept would have been
yo I'm a fan
you do this off you know I mean I
wouldn't enjoy it yeah like
okay I get to have LL do my favorite LL
songs and he gonna have me do his
favorite Ice Cube song right and it's
not verses but it's it's love it's like
that's the way yo dude yeah do this and
then he do rock the bells and he asked
me yo do once upon a time in the
projects and I'll do it you know it's
like it that's that would have been my
concept I can't go against
you know people I admire you know LL is
an OG to me of course in the game uh so
I can't see it me and Scarface you know
um
I know they love each other me and
Scarface love each other but we don't we
don't communicate
enough to do it versus together well
when they when they get there right it
was love I was like oh this is just
gonna be two friends concert for Us
online they had to talk me into it I
wouldn't do it I refuse to do it we
talked with Verses first came out yeah
he's like hey man because we talk about
all kind of stuff he's like would you do
it versus
I'm like no I would never do that like
I'm not like and and and sort of what
cube is saying my catalog is to
it's too sacred to even like put it up
for a debate on like a battle or like
let me battle my catalog and she's like
get out of here man like this right this
is this is like a sacred Indian burial
ground like you can't walk on this you
can't put this up for competition so I
could be up there having one of my
favorite MCS talking greasy and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying just or if you just
had to smash him yeah
cause you got a lot of hits yeah it's
not we agreed on it we agreed on it and
it's gonna be a celebration yeah it's
gonna be a celebration so we just went
up there and had fun we were we wasn't
tripping and that's that's what it felt
like stupid DMX had a good spirit yeah
yeah but you know I I got crazy you know
after that you know three six one got
heavy Too Short E40 My Favorite was
Gucci and Jeezy because I know the
Atlanta History that [ __ ] was crazy that
was dope I was just you know had that
butter knife out cutting attention in
the air that was that was thick I think
Jada though was like the MVP of version
because he kind of like single-handedly
like because he went Saturday showed
everybody like look you got to him
because he understood oh that's another
person I want to do a song with Jadakiss
Jadakiss all these years because I want
to do a song with the locks period name
my phone so no it ain't nothing but love
respect every time style speakers
I respect them all yeah